lever les mains ah bah y en a beaucoup
c'est bien et bien moi aussi vous fait
baisser les mains maintenant c'est bien
ça mon tour et bien moi aussi je me lève
tous les matins le lundi et les autres
jours en me disant chouette je vais
travailler je vais rencontrer marc louis
ou asma est ensemble on va faire quelque
chose d'intéressant
dutil de gratifiant bref je suis
heureuse aller au travail
j'ai la chance non en fait tout le monde
devrait être heureux d'aller travailler
et pas seulement les trois quarts de la
salle qui ont levé les mains aujourd'hui
mais tout le monde
en effet on passe un tiers de notre vie
au travail
alors c'est ma conviction aujourd'hui
mais ça n'a pas toujours été le cas
pendant longtemps j'ai vécu en région
parisienne j'étais salarié d'une grosse
entreprise et tous les jours je prenais
le métro pour aller travailler et tous
les jours à 7 heures du matin je
croisais les mêmes gens le regard
fatigué nous étions des fourmis
rejoignant leur lieu de travail et le
soir les mêmes fourmis regagnant notre
fourmilière c'était magique
c'est la vie de millions de gens et si
on remplace le métro par les
embouteillages
c'est peut-être la vie de certains
d'entre vous aujourd'hui vous vous
sentez comme une fourmi qui a compris sa
tâche du mieux possible bien sûr n'en
pensant we can en vacances la retraite
peut-être enfin un moment où vous serez
enfin libre et heureux c'est à 7
pas qu'en 2014 exactement que je suis
tombé sur une émission de télévision
intitulée le bonheur au travail ce soir
là j'avais allumé mon poste intriguée
par ce titre un peu paradoxal d'autant
plus que le sous titre étaient les
entreprises libérés de leurs patrons
deuxième paradoxe
et quand j'ai éteint mon poste une heure
et demie plus tard le monde avait changé
je me sentais comme copernic
après avoir vu l'ombre de la terre
passez sur la lune je ne sais pas si
vous vous souvenez avant copernic
la terre était le centre du monde et les
étoiles tourner autour des autour d'elle
et puis un jour
copernic à observer une éclipse de lune
comme des milliers de personnes avant
lui
là il a compris que ce qu'il voyait dans
sa lunette c'était l'ombre de la terre
qui se déplaçait sur la lune et l'ordre
des choses à changer
c'est ce qu'on a appelé la révolution
copernicienne bien pour moi ce reportage
sur le bonheur au travail
ça a été le même genre de révélations
tout à coup le monde dans lequel je
vivais n'était plus le même ce que
j'avais vu dans le reportage était
tellement tellement éloigné de ce que je
vivais à l'époque
mais tellement tellement logique dans
ces entreprises d'ici libérer les gens
relais du pouvoir sur leur destin de
l'autonomie et en particulier les gens
qui produisent les ouvriers les
techniciens les vendeurs mois en 2014
j'étais une petite fourmi dans une
organisation bien rodée et sans aucune
autonomie et sans aucune responsabilité
dans ces entreprises dites libérer les
gens se sentaient responsables les uns
des autres responsables de leurs
collègues responsables de leurs clients
responsables de leur entreprise et moi
en 2014
j'étais entouré de petites fourmis qui
dépensait beaucoup d'énergie pour
attirer l'attention du chef et avoir une
promotion meilleur ou plus rapide que la
petite fourmi d'à côté et puis
ça avait l'air de marcher dans ces
entreprises dites libérer les gens
avaient l'air heureux et les entreprises
en bonne santé alors j'étais
enthousiaste mais j'étais convaincu que
dans certaines conditions c'était
possible d'être heureux au travail
oui mais voilà en 2014
je n'avais absolument aucun moyen de
modifier les conditions dans lesquelles
je travaillais et puis un certain nombre
de métro a passé et un jour on m'a
proposé de prendre la direction de la
filiale réunionnaise de cette grosse
société
je suis arrivée à la réunion j'ai trouvé
une entreprise formidable des équipes
formidables mais une entreprise qui
était passé par des moments difficiles
et des équipes affectées par cette
histoire récente
méfiante avec une réelle opposition
entre la direction et les salariés
et vous voyez encore aujourd'hui
expliquer la situation avec ses mots me
met mal à l'aise parce que cette
division dans l'entreprise est vraiment
étrangère à la conception de
l'entreprise
après tout on est tous dans le même
bateau dans les premiers mois de ma
présence à la réunion
j'ai eu la chance de passer par une
enquête de satisfaction des salariés une
enquête grande enquête qui a lieu dans
le monde entier dans cette société dans
laquelle je travaille encore et là ça a
été un électrochoc
les résultats pour la filiale n'était
pas bon et surtout il est en nette
dégradation par rapport à l'enquêté
précédente
deux ans auparavant un élément
particulier m'a beaucoup choqué parmi la
centaine de questions qui étaient posées
l'une d'elles était formulaire ainsi
dans mon entreprise
tout le monde est respectée quel que
soit son travail et il fallait se
positionner sur une échelle de 1 à 5
entre pas du tout d'accord et tout à
fait d'accord et à cette question seuls
50 % des collaborateurs ont répondu
qu'ils étaient d'accord dans cette
entreprise dont je venais de prendre la
direction
une personne sur deux considéré qu'elle
n'était pas respecté c'était
supportable il fallait absolument faire
quelque chose pour redonner le sourire
et la confiance et qu'ensemble nous
créions un environnement où ne soyons
heureux
alors j'ai commencé à réfléchir
et là je me suis souvenu de cette
émission sur le bonheur au travail que
j'avais vu deux heures deux ans
auparavant et j'ai commencé la
révolution copernicienne
et puis il ya quelques mois j'ai eu de
la chance immense de rencontrer le
patron d'une entreprise libéré française
une des personnes qui n'avaient fait
rêver dans ce reportage
d'autant plus qu'après avoir libéré son
entreprise il part pour faire un tour du
monde en bateau et cette personne nous a
raconté l'histoire son histoire
personnelle et l'histoire de son
entreprise un petit peu quand je le fais
avec vous aujourd'hui
et surtout il a répondu aux innombrables
questions qui se posent parce qu'on est
dans un monde centré sur une
organisation pyramidale de travail et
l'entreprise libéré c'est un monde rond
qui se meut grâce à l'énergie les
collaborateurs mais qui sont des vrais
collaborateurs qui travaillent ensemble
qu laborie et des tas de questions
pratiques se pose alors quand on lui
demandait mais comment on fait dans tel
ou tel cas il répondait j'ai fait ci et
ça a marché où j'ai fait ça et ça n'a
pas marché mais jamais jamais vous devez
faire si vous devez faire ça à la
question est comment je fais moi pour
libérer mon entreprise
jean françois zobrist qui est le premier
des patrons français à l'avoir fait à
l'habitude de répondre par est il des
et vous c'est un peu brutal je vous la
corde mais quel merveilleux message ce
soir là je suis rentré chez moi avec
quatre précieux bagage un concept sur ce
que j'étais en train de faire la
certitude que j'avais raison de le faire
la conviction qu'il y avait un chemin
pour y arriver et que ce chemin ne
pouvait être que le mien depuis ce jour
de projet en projet de tâtonnements en
tâtonnements
j'ai donné plus d'autonomie plus de
responsabilités plus de liberté pour
vous donner un exemple
ça a commencé par la création d'une
salle innovation un jour quelqu'un a dit
ça serait chouette on est un lieu pour
travailler nos projets innovants un
endroit qui change des salles de réunion
habituelle vous savez c'est ça qu'on a
tous dans nos organisations grandes
tables et chaises autour décoration un
peu impersonnel bien oui pourquoi pas
qui est-ce qui veut travailler sur le
sujet des volontaires de différents
services se sont manifestés ils ont
formé un groupe et de ce groupe à
émerger un leader naturel
c'était pas le plus gradé ce n'était pas
le plus expérimenté
c'était quelqu'un avec des compétences
techniques mais surtout une grande
motivation pour le projet et un certain
leadership naturel et au début ce leader
choisi par le groupe venait me voir à
chaque étape ou à chaque idée nouvelle
pour valider avec moi assez normal c'est
comme ça qu'on fait d'habitude
un jour je lui ai dit écoute tant que
vous restez dans enveloppe budgétaire
qui est allouée à ce projet je vous fais
confiance
vous faites ce que vous voulez et quatre
mois et demi
on a inauguré notre salle innovation
qu'on a appelé la casino et elle est
magnifique
d'abord c'est
biodynamique comme l'amphithéâtre dans
lequel nous sommes rafraîchi par les
courants d'air naturel
les murs sont bleu turquoise tout le
mobilier est fait avec du matériel de
récupération des palettes des bidons
d'huile et touré et puis on a une table
bien sûr parce que même quand on
travaille sur des projets innovants bah
faut bien poser ses affaires quelque
part mais quand elle ne sert pas de
table de réunion
cette table inserts de table de ping
pong à chaque fois qu'on laisse les
équipes s'organiser de façon transverse
en complète autonomie sur un projet qui
sont choisis le résultat est fantastique
et vous savez pourquoi
bien quand on fait quelque chose qu'on a
envie de faire qu'on applique des
décisions qu'on a pris soin même qu'on
met en oeuvre des compétences qu'on a on
a envie d'acquérir en effet bien non et
quand on est plus
hier avec des compétences différentes à
travailler sur un projet qu'on a choisi
appliquer des décisions qu'on a pris
soin même dans le cadre d'une vision
partagée en est puissant et on est
efficace c'est banal ça paraît tellement
évident mais quelle organisation
fonctionne comme ça j'ai commencé cette
démarche de façon consciente et
structuré il ya un environ c'est long et
compliqué parce qu'il s'agit de bâtir la
confiance et que rien n'est jamais
acquis
on a fait beaucoup de choses déjà en
plus de cette salino un groupe de
parents organisé une fête de noël pour
les enfants des collaborateurs général
dans les sociétés crh qui s'occupe de ça
et cette fête a lieu cet après midi même
je suis sûr qu'elle va être super un
autre groupe composé de volontaires
différents à travailler à créer et
animer une enquête de satisfaction des
collaborateurs au fil de l'eau pour ne
pas attendre la grosse enquête qui
tombent du siège tous les deux ans un
troisième groupe a travaillé sur
l'organisation du travail et la mise en
place du télétravail
et puis on peut faire beaucoup plus j'en
suis sûr mais on apprend ensemble en
avançant
a de plus en plus d'organisations choisi
cette voie des pme des grands groupes
d'administration d'aegis et même j'ai
entendu récemment les uns après les
autres chacun à sa manière
on est en train de construire un monde
meilleur un monde où le travail pourrait
être source de bonheur alors peut-être
que vous vous dites en quoi ça me
concerne après tout c'est facile pour
elle elle est directrice elle fait ce
qu'elle veut
oui c'est vrai je suis directrice et
j'ai le pouvoir de changer les choses
dans mon organisation mais peut-être que
certains d'entre vous ici ont aussi ce
pouvoir de changer les choses dans leur
service dans leur entreprise
j'espère vous avoir convaincus que
c'était possible d'être est de rendre
les autres heureux au travail et si vous
me demandez comment faire je vous
répondrais débrouillez vous
m
et pour ceux d'entre vous pour ceux
d'entre vous qui n'ont pas le pouvoir de
changer les choses dans leur
organisation
parce que c'est quand même le cas de la
majorité des gens aujourd'hui j'ai envie
de vous dire une révolution est en
marche et elle nous concernera un jour
en attendant vous avez toujours la
possibilité de diffuser largement cette
idée pour qu'elle atteigne le plus vite
possible les gens qui décident dans vos
organisations cet idéal est simple c'est
possible d'être est de rendre les autres
heureux au travail en pratiquant la
confiance merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]